well he did uh at one point
he fainted and kind of he had a collapse
and uh
he told me that he could see himself
going down a dark tunnel and
he didn't know if he was dying or
leaving this reality or
what was happening to him
he gone to the threshold maybe of his
sanity or something
it was scary but also kind of
exhilarating
or thrilling that he would take such
risks with himself and his
uh experience to go that far and i think
this film was all about risking risking
your money risking your uh
your insanity risking your how far you
can press your
family members i mean everything that he
did he went to the extremes
to test those fringe regions
and then come back nothing is so
terrible as a pretentious movie i mean a
movie
that aspires for something really
terrific and doesn't pull it off
is [ __ ] it's scum and everyone will walk
on it as such and that's why poor
filmmakers in a way that's their
greatest horror is to be pretentious
so here you are on one hand that's
trying to aspire to really do something
on the other hand you're not allowed to
be pretentious and finally you say [ __ ]
it
i don't care if i'm pretentious or not
pretentious or if i've done it or i
haven't done all
i know is that i am going to see this
movie and that for me
it has to have some answers and my
answers i don't mean just a punch line
answers
on about 47 different levels and it's
very hard to talk about these things
without being very corny
you use a word like self-purgation or
epiphany they think you're either
you know a religious weirdo or a you
know an [ __ ] college professor but
those are the words for the process this
transmutation
this renaissance this rebirth
which is the basis of all life the one
rule that all man
from the time they first were walking
around looking up at the
sun scratching around for food and an
animal to kill the first
concept that i feel got into their head
was the idea of
life and death that the sun went down
and the sun went up
that the animal cropped when they
learned how to make a crop it died in
the winter everything died and
to the first man he must have thought oh
my god is the end of the world and then
all of a sudden
there was spring and everything came
alive and it was better i mean after all
i mean look at vietnam look at my movie
you'll see what i'm talking